you know it wasn't until 1973 that the
American Psychiatric Association after a
fairly lengthy period of debate
discussion and advocacy voted to remove
homosexuality as a mental disorder
discrimination you know comes in of
course in many forms and the
psychological and the social
implications of those are you know
they're not insignificant so if you do
surveys of physicians and health care
providers about their attitudes towards
LGBT people 20 to 30 percent say you
know I'm really not comfortable
providing this kind of care do does one
come out on an application to college or
to medical school or to law school or
you know you name it
these are questions that you know people
struggle with even to this very day 90%
or so of LGBT kids definitely say that
they've experienced this kind of thing
on a kind of on a daily basis whether
it's being told or being called
or whatever made made to feel badly
because they're different these kinds of
things over time you know sort of had up
discrimination actual and perceived then
this expectation that develops for those
those events results in lower self
esteem difficulty with relationships
difficulty with one's own feeling happy
about one's own life there is probably a
two and a half or so times likelihood of
mental health disorders or problems
among LGBT folks depression anxiety
substance use in particular in
particular for women actually about
three and a half times rate of substance
use disorders among lesbians and
bisexual women there are higher rates of
certainly attempted suicide among LGBT
communities exactly how many of those
are completed is harder to know but I I
could certainly say just from our
clinical work over the years it's
certainly not an uncommon kind of
scenario unfortunately
there's just no question that today is
there's just you know 180 degrees
different than the way it was when I was
growing up in small towns in the Midwest
as a middle-aged man suddenly I was able
to you know fight in the in the armed
services when DOMA went down in the 90s
now today I can actually be married in
all 50 states the fact that that has
happened over this period of what 50
years or so is really quite remarkable
as those negative attitudes lessen I
can't help but think that there's going
to be lesser mental health problems
among LGBT folks